- We are standing in front
of Jose Clemente Orozco's
Dive Bomber and Tank, painted in 1940.
And my name is Lauren Adelman.
We're right by the escalators
right now, and the kids,
when they come into the
museum, they kinda like
come up the escalator and see this,
whether we're gonna look at it or not,
and I would say nine times out of 10
kids are drawn to it, all ages.
Probably starting with
like fourth grade and up,
they're like, "What is that?
"I love that, it looks likes graffiti.
"Is that graffiti?"
So students at first
are really interested,
in like the first point
of entry are these faces.
And what does it mean that one of
these faces has chains in its mouth?
Does that mean that it's
losing the right to speak?
And then they often
talk about this one here
that has nails going into the eyes.
A lot of students connect that to
losing the ability to see the truth.
And then they talk about
like, this feeling of weight
that's underneath everything,
and then as we start to
discuss the top and how there's
actually a lot more space,
a lot of students aren't
interested in saying,
"Oh, that orange thing is this."
It's like what do they
feel is bearing down?
What do they feel is keeping
this group of people down?
You know, they talk about slavery,
they talk about oppression.
And then often, like
these legs are brought up
and people are like, "Is
someone getting sucked into it,"
or, "Is someone getting crushed?"
I had a group of students
who I was working with
and they just were so
drawn to the symbolism.
They would talk about how you
could almost like, feel it.
Like, it's one of those paintings
that you could almost feel this weight,
and you could almost feel like,
these chains in you as you look at it.